Jorge Ramos is an anchor at Univision
he's the author of stranger the
challenge of a Latino immigrant in the
Trump era and he joins us tonight all
right thanks for coming on hey great to
be here so I understand why Mexico wants
to export its ports the United States
I'm sure if we can export our poor to
Canada some people would be in favor of
it not me but some but what I don't
understand is why America is denounced
as racist for not wanting that why is it
racist to say it's our border we
determine who comes here no you know
first of all let me just say that I
don't speak for the Mexican government
I've been criticizing the Mexican
government for decades I as a matter of
fact I left Mexico because of censorship
so I don't speak for the Mexican
government okay now what I what I do
understand is when when you are
president from saying that makes you go
has to pay for a useless wall Mexican
simply don't like that and when you have
a politician in June 2015 saying that
Mexican immigrants are criminals and
drug traffickers in rapists and that's a
racist statement Mexicans simply don't
like that that's the problem we don't
know Trump are rejecting Donald Trump
and his government okay I understand
that but I mean let's be honest if you
were to do an actual measure of racism
Mexico is a formal racist country that
in the United States I mean the last
four presidents have all been white
people who went to Harvard or Yale it's
a totally unequal Society it's not the
most unequal in the world I'm not
attacking it but I'm just saying
discrimination in Mexico there's no
Mexico I just think a little perspective
is in order here that's a little much
for the offspring of conquistadors to be
saying you're racist if you want a
border by the way when we get there we
deserve affirmative action like what
this is crazy can we be honest about it
or no I think we can be honest about it
yeah there's discrimination here in the
United States and there's also
discrimination in Mexico absolutely now
the United States does have the right to
a border a secure border I have I have
absolutely no problem with that but I
don't think that bringing the military
to the to the border is the right
solution I think it's going to be a
waste a monumental waste of time and
resources the same as building this
useless wall between
both countries I think what we really
need is a legal system a legal
immigration system that works and it
isn't working right now okay so there's
no doubt it's no work but it's not
working but what you're saying is we
need to just legalize everyone who snuck
in how about you say the United States
has a right to say you know we've got a
lot of low-skilled workers already
Automation is is eliminating their jobs
we don't want anymore how about that and
maybe Mexico should stop allowing
hundreds of thousands of Central
Americans to cross the length the 2,500
miles of its country into the US maybe
Mexico could help and we wouldn't need a
wall why is that it raised the idea well
I think there are two points right here
Tucker one has to do with the fact that
many undocumented immigrants are here in
the United States because of us they're
doing many of the jobs that we don't
want to do so that's that's one point
and that's why I think we have the
responsibility to legalize them 11
million of them now talking about
Central Americans crossing from Mexico
to the United States I think finally the
United States and Donald Trump they
realized that they need Mexico to
control immigration maybe this is
Mexico's bargaining chip if I think
after President Ron said that Mexican
immigrants were criminals and rapists
and after threatening to end NAFTA and
after trying to make Mexico pay for the
wall now he has realized that after all
the attacks and insults now he needs
Mexico and that's that's our wait a
second I mean without illegal aliens in
the United States Mexico would collapse
as I said remittances are the single
largest source of hard currency in
Mexico and it's not yet more that
probably not more than fentanyl or
cocaine that's probably number one but
we don't have the exact numbers on that
but why can't we be honest and say
Mexico wouldn't exist without sending
its poor here and well we should call on
them to do something to control the
border and if they don't why wouldn't we
build a wall I don't understand where's
their obligation in this you know I want
to say Mexico wouldn't exist as a matter
of fact Mexico existed before the United
States so that's that's a completely
different story and then remittances are
incredibly important to the Mexican
economy but also you have to remember
there are many other resources tourism
and oil an incredibly important I agree
Mexico wouldn't exist without the United
States that's absolutely false no but
look and actually this is America's
fault I do think to a small degrees we
spent an awful lot of time trying to
improve countries across the globe and
not enough paying attention to Latin
America this is a problem because the
Mexican government is dysfunctional in
its leaders steal the money and leave
and have houses in Switzerland so why
don't you and people like you and me to
put pressure on the Mexican government
to serve its own people and then maybe
they wouldn't have to send eleven
million people here to say I do agree
with you I do agree with you on that
I've been criticizing the Mexican
government for corruption more than yeah
and I've said the these government with
Enrique Pena Nieto more than a hundred
thousand people would have been killed
just in these government so that's
that's something that we cannot stand
and what I'm noticing right now is by
having donors from criticizing Mexico
and Mexicans now it seems that he's
helping the most anti from candidate to
go ahead and in the next election that
we're gonna happen July the first that's
I think you're voting in by the way
since you're a dual citizen
yeah but can we disagree on this point
that a country that exterminated its
black population that is run exclusively
by white people that had a caste system
based on blood until pretty recently
probably shouldn't be calling us racist
can we take let's take that out of the
equation this is an economic argument
about who benefits from migration it's
not really about race I don't think no
no I think we we I think we should
criticize both countries if they're
discrimination in Mexico and there's a
lot of discrimination we have to say
that but when we have a president like
president from who's made racist
statements who clearly wants to make
America white again by bringing no wait
when he said that he wants to bring
immigrants from Norway and not from
Haiti and from Africa don't you think
that's a racist statement
besides that 85% of our immigrants are
non-weight it's not a question of white
or non-white it's a question of whether
Mexico gets to use the United States as
its welfare system by the way there were
two seconds notion is the Mexico because
they were black two countries they've
never been to that's what it's like to
be african-american in Mexico good luck
with that so let's just stop with the
race stuff there's a lot of racism in
Mexico but immigration is simply a
matter of supply and demand and it's we
have to understand it's an economic
phenomenon I agree totally agree with
that so let's drop the moral cudgel of
race so we can have a rational adult
conversation about this rather than
mudding it with this college student
nonsense about identity politics that
that would be mine oh thank you very
much Jorge I think you [ __ ] you're
coming up Thank You Tucker